allez c'est l'heure de notre page était
aujourd'hui à loches la ville où est né
l'écrivain gonzague fabrice disparu dans
un accident de voiture au début du mois
d'août
à la veille de la forêt des livres le
festival littéraire qu'il a fondé on
retrouve flavien texier aujourd'hui
flavien pour nous emmener sur les traces
de cet homme de lettres et oui bonsoir
olivia on vous attendait avec impatience
on est là depuis un moment nous pour
vous parler de gonzague vous l'avez dit
on va aller sur les traces du grand
écrivain ici à loches
mais juste avant olivier regarder je
veux vous montrer quelque chose ça se
passe juste derrière moi c'est la ville
de loches tels que vous ne l'avez jamais
vue et pour cause nous sommes installés
ce soir sur un promontoire inaccessible
au grand public
vous l'avez dit gonzague était né ici en
1948 on va ce soir modestement vous
raconter quelques instants de sa vie
dans le lochois grâce aux archives de la
télé et surtout grâce à pascal du brisé
l'ancien adjoint à la culture de la
ville de loches bonsoir monsieur marc
flavien merci infiniment d'être avec
nous quand on a préparé ce direct tous
les deux vous m'avez dit faut pas être
triste il faut raconter gonzague l'homme
qui aimait la vie
oui parce que gonzague c'était un être
éclectique il a été journaliste il a été
animateur radio il est devenu patron de
presse
écrivain historien bref il est décliné
en quantité de formule et pour faire ce
qu'il a fait il ne pouvait aimer la vie
et c'est vrai gonzague c'était un
tourbillon permanent quelqu'un qui oui
et mais la fête à tout instant mais
toujours en étant extrêmement sérieux
dans tout ce qu'il faisait
c'est ce paradoxe que je voudrais
souligner ce soir parce que vraiment
même dans les moments sérieux et bien il
savait nous fait rire et s'amuser
on parle souvent du clos lucé à amboise
où il a passé une partie de son enfance
est vrai qu'on parle moins de los ché
pourtant et bien l'os et gonzague
c'est une grande histoire oui parce que
d'abord il a jamais pu oublier un seul
instant que c'était sa ville natale
la ville d'agnès sorel dont il avait une
passion folle et puis la ville des
plantagenêts c'est plantagenet pour
lesquelles il a essayé d'installer le
fameux pays plantagenet qui aurait pu
permettre de décliner cette région et
gonzague saint brice et mais les stars à
la fin des années 80 on disait pas
encore people et vous allez voir il fait
venir quelqu'un de très connu à loches
on regarde on se retrouve juste après
addax et monuments légué par le
moyen-âge loches a gardé la nostalgie du
millénaire précédent
mais il suffit du passage d'une star
pour voir la population locale se mettre
à rêver sur son destin
[Musique]
oui bien sûr c'est un événement
grandiose c'est le mozart de la musique
il est à la fois un peintre des villes
il est à la fois un musicien des mondes
il est à la fois un décorateur de
l'écologie il est à la fois un
inspirateur de la jeunesse et c'est ça
qui fait sa grandeur
[Musique]
j'avais prévu pour maman c'est sympa je
pencherais bonne bien pour la ville de
larache certainement surtout s'il fait
un concert dans la région
dans un château en château de la loire
je garde ça peut très bien vous savez le
problème de loches c'est que nous sommes
enclavés dans le sud profond et grâce au
coup de laser donné par jean michel
aujourd'hui loches et moins inconnus
qu'ils n'étaient hier avant de revenir
en touraine jean michel jarre on va
éviter un nouvel album à loches la fête
est finie il y en aura d'autres le vrai
travail commence retour ici en direct
depuis los pascal dû briser il y avait
deux stars on l'a vu dans ce reportage y
avait jean michel jarre mais il y avait
également gonzague car il aimait se
mettre en scène
on aimait il pouvait pas en être
autrement il faut toujours avoir à
l'esprit qu'il a été l'initiateur des
clips culturel et lorsqu'il s'est
présenté à loches dans l'équipe
municipale
ça a été un argument fort de cette
campagne justement il a mis en lice et
mis en scène à travers ses clips
culturel et bien justement on va
regarder un court extrait de l'un de ses
clips auxquels il a participé
un candidat culturel c'est quelqu'un qui
veut créer en équipe et ici à loches la
création culturelle a déjà commencé je
ne ferai que rejoindre une équipe
[Musique]
on va terminer cet hommage avec quelques
images exceptionnelles on a eu le
privilège de les tourner cet après midi
c'est donc la première fois que vous
allez les voir à la télé c'est la
chambre de gonzague saint-bris ce qui se
trouve en fait chez vous pascal dû
briser
racontez-moi en quelques mots oui
pendant cette fameuse campagne
municipale gonzague est venu pour
coucher un soir à la maison parce qu'il
avait raté son train et puis finalement
il y rester durant six années par
intermittence et grâce à cela on a vécu
des choses extraordinaires et aux clés
parce que il a beaucoup réfléchi dans
cette chambre bien sûr il ya dormi mais
il y a écrit également un certain nombre
de ses ouvrages c'est en quelque sorte
votre petit musée secret que vous nous
avez montré ce soir pour la première
fois merci pascal dû briser vous avez
été notre mémoire en quelque sorte merci
à vous olivia demain on sera la forêt
des livres
la manifestation littéraire que gonzague
a lancé il ya 22 ans vous imaginez bien
l'émotion et surtout l'hommage qui va
lui être rendu à demain